- Is it true you shaved the
mustache earlier this year?
'Cause I don't know if I've seen you
without the mustache other than this time.
- That's the one day I
didn't have a mustache.
- That's so crazy.
- I started growin' it in the summer
between the 11th and the 12th grade.
And so I've been with my wife for 36 years
and she had never seen me without it
because I never had a break
where I wasn't doin' either
a concert or a TV show.
And then when they
started canceling shows,
I thought, "All right, I
got time to shave it off."
And I didn't even say anything.
I just went in the
bathroom and shaved it off
and I walked out and she
looked at me and said,
"Oh wow, grow it back."
And so I literally shaved
my lip one time as an adult.
'Cause I didn't know how
long it took to grow it back,
but it takes between
two and three weeks, so.
- I guess, depending on the person.
You're a Chia Pet,
that's awesome. (laughs)
- Well, but here was the funny thing,
so I posted it on Instagram
and there were some people that were like,
"Oh wow, you look younger."
But Kelly, I swear, 80% of 'em were like,
"No, no, no, you are
supposed to have a mustache.
Grow it back."
- It's like Tom Selleck for me.
You have to have a mustache.
He has to have a mustache.
It's just what we're used to.
- Sam Elliott does not
look right without one.
- Sam Elliott, Sam Elliott,
best cowboy ever.
Yes, he has to have one too.